with the matrix resurrections heading to
theaters and hbo max later this year
it's an exciting time to be a fan of the
classic franchise keanu reeves and
carrie anne masters are reprising their
roles as neo and trinity and they're in
cahoots a few other returning stars the
explosive first trailer for the sequel
recently arrived with mostly praise from
fans online and although it teased what
to expect it also gave us other
mysteries to try and solve ahead of the
film's december release date one of the
most important questions of all is how
neo and trinity are even in the film
since they seemingly die at the end of
the matrix revolutions a blink in your
misses chart shows neo being worked on
by machines and he still has the ice
scars from being blinded by bane
meanwhile the later shots seem to show a
living trinity being put back into the
matrix things are clearly going to get
weird the new trailer also showed off
the new actors joining the franchise for
the first time like the blue head
jessica henwick neil patrick harris and
of course yaya abdul mateen ii his role
had been kept under wraps but this first
footage implied that he's going to be
much more important to the story than
many initially expected yaya went ahead
and finally confirmed what fans have
suspected all along the actor posted on
instagram a still from the trailer of
himself in a dark orange suit with a gun
in each hand and catch the caption short
and sweet simply writing morpheus guess
that settles it but as usual yaya's
involvement only gives us more questions
about the nature of this latest sequel
he seems to be playing a younger version
of morpheus while keanu and carrie anne
most are playing neo in trinity at their
respective actual ages reeves previously
explained on bbc's the one show that
there's no time travel in the film
saying no going in the past it's another
version a call to wake up and it has
some great action all will be revealed
as such that would seem to indicate that
this has to be a brand new iteration of
morpheus perhaps one that's been
affected by the matrix being rebooted at
the end of revolutions obviously many
hardcore matrix fans are concerned over
lawrence fishburne not being in the film
and there's a surprising reason behind
his absence the star himself told real
blends jake hamilton i'm not involved
before also adding the only thing i can
tell you is that lana wachowski can
answer those questions for you better
than i can his explanation implies that
the story specifically calls for a new
morpheus rather than a rewritten script
to accommodate any external issues like
scheduling conflicts or contract
negotiations that's something echoed by
report from variety back in 2019 warner
brothers was allegedly originally
looking at a variety of actors to follow
in lawrence fishburne's footsteps for
the role and clearly the studio found
his successor in yaya abdul mateen ii
it's worth noting that it's possible
fishburn might still appear in the film
as a version of morpheus we all know and
love but announcing his involvement
could ruin a third act twist or the
meats and bones of the story itself but
if fans really have seen the last of
fish burn in the role at least there's
still an entire trilogy of movies
featuring morpheus as a main character
for now we'll just have to wait and see
how yaya abdul mateen ii's version of
the character plays into the story and
since he's a terrific performer he'll
definitely do it justice the matrix
resurrections arrives in theaters and on
hbo max on december 22nd 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the matrix are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]